Hey everyone, it's Michael Baltos from
Orderflows and today I'm going to do a
quick video on volume imbalance
thresholds in orderflow and talk a
little bit about uh imbalances in
general. Now, you know, there's several
building blocks in orderflow and
imbalances are one of them. Um I would
consider imbalances, point of control,
delta sort of be the foundation of order
flow. And you know what imbalances are?
They show you when
aggressive buyers or aggressive sellers
are really being dominant in the market.
Now, you know, we often, you know, in
the old days when when you're trading um
through a broker, you'd call your broker
up and say, "Hey, why is the market
rallying?" Well, they'll say more buyers
than sellers, which is basically a way
of saying, "I don't know." Because, you
know, there's never more buyers than
sellers. You know, it's a zero- sum game
in the sense that for every buyer,
there's a seller. But what you can have
is periods where there's more aggressive
buying than selling and imbalances
really highlight that to a trader. So
before we begin, uh brief disclaimer.
This presentation is for
educationalformational purposes only. It
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
make any type investment decision.
Futures trading contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor. An
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment. Risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle. Only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. Now, I'm
not saying, oh, just because you have a
imbalance of a certain percent or a
certain volume, you go out and you buy
the market. No, you got to take
everything in context. You know, it's
one piece of the trading puzzle. You
know, put it together with the other
pieces and then you start to see the
broader picture and the market will make
a lot more sense to you as a trader. So
the tools I use in this presentation are
the orderflows trader software that's
available on my website orderflows.com.
So a question came up recently from one
of my users and
question was about uh imbalance volume
thresholds and
you know why I have it set at 50 um
versus you know one or 10 or 15. Why I
use 50? Well, if you go into the
settings, right, there's two things as
far as imbalance that you really want to
I'll say play around with, but you know,
find your sweet spot. You know, find the
level that you're comfortable. Imbalance
trigger in percent is 400, which is
400%. So, what that means is
the ratio between the bid and the offer
diagonally has got to be 4:1. you know,
four, you know, the for an imbalance to
print, it has to be four times for a
buying imbalance to to print, there has
to be four times as many volume traded
on the offer as traded on the bid. And
imbalance volume threshold is the
minimum volume that needs to trade for
the imbalance to show. So
if the volume traded on the bid is four
and the imbalance and the volume traded
on the offer is uh 15 technically that's
an imbalance by over 400%. 4 to one
or sorry um be uh four against we'll
call it 20 um it' have to be 16 but um
you know we'll call it four against 20.
Okay, that would be an imbalance of over
4:1. And
the imbalance is showing because now if
you set the imbalance threshold at 50,
it's not going to show up on your chart.
It's not going to it'll the volume will
show up on your chart, but it won't
print as an imbalance. It'll just print
as a normal normal trade because it
didn't meet the minimum imbalance volume
threshold of 50. Now, if you set it at
say two, it will show up, you know, or
10, it will show up. So why is that
important? Well, in markets that trade
lesser volume during the day, it can be
important, especially depending on the
type of chart you're using. If you're
using a shortterm chart and you know
you're like say u you know a one minute
chart in the eourcurrencies or NASDAQ
and you have it set at 50, chances are
you're not going to get any imbalances.
Okay, the volume because, you know, such
a short-term chart, it's you just don't
get the volume of 50 lots at each price
level um in that bar. So, you know,
let's just take a look at a couple of
charts really quick and I'll explain it
and you should understand it um
hopefully a bit uh a bit better. So, for
example, um you know, we'll start with
this.
Okay, I'll start with this. This is a
S&P one minute chart. Okay. So,
you know, this one the imbalance volume
threshold is set at 50. Now, on a market
like S&Ps, it's not going to be a
problem because it trades very good
volume, right? So, even if you know, you
each price level, you're getting, you
know, generally sever several hundred at
a price level. You can see it here, but
you're getting a lot of imbalances on a
minute-based chart. Now, that's why, you
know, I'm not a big fan of minute-based
charts because you use minute-based
charts. Well, it says it's 10:00. This
is the bar. 10:01, we got another bar.
And I don't like it where, you know,
it's it's oh, it's 10:01, we got to
close and start a new bar. 10:02, close,
got to start a new bar. You know, over
these over this 5 minutes here, the
market was just basically going from bid
to offer and bid offer like that. You
know, rotating around this price here at
36 and a quarter. Um, you know, to me
that, you know, looking at that on a
minute-based chart is there's nothing of
value. When you start breaking it down
to say a,
you know, a rangebased chart, which
shows how the market moves, you know,
from price level to price level, you
know, it moves are a lot cleaner and a
lot more, uh, clearer, right? You can
see, you know, how how the market is
moving price related rather than just
time related. So, you know, we form a
new bar when the bar closes. So again,
you know, on a rangebased charts, the
market looks a lot cleaner and more
clearer, I believe. So, you know, if
you're looking at a rangebased chart or
any type of chart on the S&Ps, you got
very good volume, right? Every imbalance
you see is above 50. So, you know,
having imbalanced volume threshold level
on a market like S&Ps, 5 years, bonds,
doesn't really matter that much,
honestly, um because you just put in
such good volume in in in the S&Ps. Now
again, you know, I I do know people that
trade imbalances
and they're just looking for certain
numbers in the market. They're looking
for volume on imbalances above, you
know, say 2,000 here. So just this. So
if you set it at 2,000, just this
imbalance will show up. I'm talking
about the imbalance volume threshold.
this level here. If you set this level
instead of 50, if you set it to 2,00
only imbalances of 2,000 or more will
show up. So like this 607 won't show up.
832 won't show up. 2,000 will show up.
You know, none of these would show up.
This selling imbalance would show up.
This buying imbalance would show up. you
know and you know I mean some wise is
you know different things are important
to different traders okay so you know
find your sweet spot you know something
that you know resonates with you I mean
I don't want to go and say hey you know
set it at 200 and just look for those
well
if if you're not going to believe in it
you know and trust it then it's
pointless to say just look for
imbalances at 200 and buy it or sell
when you know when it comes in but um
you know I mean you have to also have
faith and confidence in your trading
ability ilities to understand, you know,
why you have an imbalance of such a big
volume and why that's important.
And you know, just really quick, you
know, another thing is this imbalance
trigger in percent 400. Okay, it's 4
400%. So
for the imbalance to show up, right, it
has to be a ratio of 4:1. So 162 against
2395 right here in this bar. You know
that's an imbalance of more than 4:1
400%. You know 72 against 1072
532 against 2234.
You know this one's very close. Now you
know there's some people I know that
like different different numbers.
There's some that use 300% 3:1 ratio.
They're going to get more imbalances.
Some tighten it up and they use 10:1
ratio. So they're only looking for
imbalances of 10 to one. Okay? So you
know while you have a big imbalance here
5591 against 716, you know, if you have
it set at a,000% 10 to1, this one's not
going to show up here. So you'll you'll
miss this big imbalance. So again, you
know, it depends on you and your trading
style, right? What you want to look for.
4:1 seems to be I would say the industry
standard but you know a lot of people
use it and you know a lot of people are
very comfortable with it and I use it
honestly. Um now again you know the
point of this video is really about this
in volume imbalance threshold imbalance
volume threshold of 50 why that's
important. So, you know, I talked about
different markets. You know, if if
you're trading different markets, some
that are more liquid than others, you're
going to get more imbalances or lesser
imbalances. So, where's my chart here?
So, let's take a look at at a different
market here,
if I could find it. Okay, so this is a
Euro currency chart.
And on this chart, I have it set at
50 right here. 50. Okay. So
now, eo currencies
tend to trade less volume. Okay. So
you'll notice you only see an imbalances
of 50 or more. However, there's
imbalances here. Five, you know, 40
against five. This is a selling
imbalance at 40. Okay.
And you know, there's other imbalances
that are not showing up in here. Um,
two against 27 right here, that's an
imbalance. And let me just go back here.
That's late in the day. So, you know,
one against nine, that's an imbalance.
One against four, that'd be an
imbalance. Um, two against seven is not.
Three against 37, right? 3 against 37 is
not showing up as an imbalance because
it's less than 50. Now,
I've got another euro currency chart
here.
This chart here shows imbalances. This
is the same chart. It's an eight range
chart.
And you'll see I have this imbalance
setting set at one here. set at one.
Okay. So, it's basically going to show
me every imbalance that's going to
appear.
So, I'll just put these two charts side
by side so it's a little bit easier to
see,
you know, at the same levels. Okay. So,
as you can see,
you know, this one is showing other, you
know, smaller imbalances. 9 against 48,
6 against 32. Time is this 10:00 here.
So whereas on this chart, you don't see
them, right? You don't see the 9 against
48 here that you see here. You don't see
the 6 against 32 here. You don't see the
8 against 36, 2 against 27 in this bar
that you see here.
And you know, is it important? Well,
yeah, it can be. you know, depending on,
you know, what you're looking at. So,
you know, earlier
time was this 9:00. So, just before
9:00. If you're using, you know, if you
have it set at a low number to show more
imbalances, you know, here you have
stacked imbalance. You don't see it on
this chart right here. All right? And
you see how the market popped up a bit
here before reversing and and selling
off. So, if you're using Whoops. If
you're using um a smaller number, you're
going to just get more imbalances. So,
again, you know, on on some markets, it
might be more telling than than others.
Um, this day you don't really have many
stacked imbalances, but you know, there
are days where you're going to get, you
know, a bunch of stacked imbalances
because you've got, you know, maybe um,
you know, 2 against 27, 3 against 12, 8
against 36, and you have an imbalance in
the stacked imbalance in there. Um, you
know, it just really depends on on your
trading style and what you're trading on
how you want to set it. You know, for
me, I I like to set it at 50, okay?
Because I I just find that, you know,
I'm comfortable with that. You know, I
like to see some decent volume going
through.
Okay.
So, you know, let me just see if I could
find a another market just really quick
to show you to highlight to you. So,
okay. Okay. Now, this is a DAX chart.
Okay. And I think I have this one set at
10 or so. Let me just double check here.
You know why I have it set at 10 is
because well, DAX trades a lot less. DAX
moves around a lot. And you know,
setting at 50, you're not going to
you're going to get very very Okay, have
it set at 15. If I have it set at 50,
I'm going to get like no imbalances
because if you notice in the bar, it's
an eight range chart.
very few bars. Just on this one snapshot
right here, you got one bar where the
trade is more than 50 in the bar.
Okay? I mean, you do get other
imbalances, you know, one against 16,
two against 17, one against 19.
So, but as you can see, right, this is a
market that's a lot thinner. You don't
necessarily get a lot of imbalance. If I
have it set at one, I'm going to get a
boatload of imbalances. One against
seven, zero against seven, zero against
six. This would be a stacked imbalance
here. you know, some of these bars with
all these zeros, when you got a zero,
it'll show up as an imbalance actually,
even though, you know, it's zero against
two. I believe that will show up as an
imbalance if you set it at uh,
you know, at one or at zero. But, so,
you know, really what I like to see, you
know, I like to see decent volume, what
I consider decent volume, and in the
DAX, you know, above 10, above 15 is
decent to me. So, as you can see, you
don't see a whole heck of a lot of um,
stacked imbalances. I mean, you see some
imbalances, but do you see any stacked?
No. Um, you know why? Because I have
that volume threshold set at at 15.
Because, you know, I want to filter it
out to what I consider decent volume.
And you this being a market that you
don't have tremendous volume the way you
have it in S&Ps or um
bonds or crude oil even, you know,
you're not seeing any any stacked
imbalances in here. And I'm fine with
that. you know, I don't want to see
imbalances. You know, I don't want this
whole bar to show up as stacked
imbalances, zeros, all zeros. You know,
to me that that's
at least to me in my analysis that
that's going to be worthless. You know,
there's nothing of value in there. So,
here you got a stacked imbalance. You
have one stacked imbalance. Three
against 17, two against 16, two against
16. You know, they all meet my
requirement of more than 4:1 ratio 400%.
And more importantly, the volume is
above 15.
And you can see the market did come off
a little bit uh before rallying and
coming off again. But again, you know,
if I have it set at one, it's going to
show a crapload of imbalances and and a
whole lot of stacked imbalances, which
is not going to be very useful to to my
trading.
So that's why, you know, that's how I
look at it. you know, for, you know,
just really quick, you know, just, you
know, some other markets, you know, most
markets I use 50. You know, soybeans, I
I have it set at 50. If I have it set at
25, I'd probably get more imbalances,
you know, zero against 13, you know, one
against 15, you know, I'd just be
getting more more and more imbalances
the lower number you go, you know, but
again, you know, it's yes, you know,
these are imbalances. 0 against 31, 6
against 36,
but it doesn't meet my minimum
requirement as far as volume analysis.
That's why I have it set at 50. You
know, if I have it set at one and just
show every single imbalance that appears
um for my style of trading, you know, to
me that that's useless information,
right? That's just information that's
going to confuse you, the trader.
Um, let me just see if I got this other
chart here.
NASDAQ. Okay, NASDAQ's a tricky one in
the sense that it's not a market that I
am active in, but you know, I do watch
it
and it's been quite volatile uh
recently. I think I have my imbalance
set at 50 on this chart,
but you know, NASDAQ is kind of similar
to the DAX, but you know, the difference
is it puts more volume and yeah, it's
set at 50. So, um,
you know, is is there any stacked
imbalances? Not really. You know, you
get close here. You got a couple there,
but you're seeing, you know, it's set at
50. So, it's showing me, you know, just
imbalances of more than 50.
Not really any stacked imbalances
yesterday or Friday rather. Um but
again, you know, if I have it set at a
smaller number, you know, some of these
would show up. I'd have a stacked
imbalance here. 9 against 39. If I have
this set at 25 or 15, I'd have stacked
imbalance right here because this would
be an imbalance. 9 against 39,
you know, 1 against 40. Those would be
imbalances.
But again, you know, I I made the
decision that, you know, in my analysis,
to me, that's not a strong enough
imbalance that I'd be interested in.
Otherwise, here you'd have a big bunch
of stacked imbalances. Four against 24,
four against 46, one against 10. You
know, here on the way up, all these
zeros, these would be this would be a
big stacked imbalance area right in
here. But again, it's it's not showing
up in there because I have it set at at
minimum of 50.
So, you know, again, you know, that's
what that hopefully that explains it and
makes it clear what you, you know, what
the setting is and why I have it set at
50. I said, you know, for most markets,
it doesn't really, you know, 50 is, I'll
say it doesn't matter. Um, for markets
that are liquid, you know, setting it at
50 isn't going to really have that much
effect because the market's deep enough
that there's enough volume being traded
that, you know, 50 is an very very easy
threshold to reach. You know, if if
you're using say, you know, this is a 10
range S&P chart, okay,
every bar has got thousands in it
practically. So setting at 50 doesn't
really matter. you know, I I if anything
I should, you know, what I would
consider doing is is maybe moving it up
to, you know, a couple thousand or
something. But again, you know,
that would be, you know, more refining
it. You know, this 50 is my general
setting that I use for most markets. So
crude, for example,
where's my crude chart?
You know, crude here. So again, I just
want to see imbalances above, you know,
above 50. You know, four against 40.
Yeah, that's an imbalance. But, you
know, I'm not interested in that because
it doesn't, you know, like here, you
know, this is why you filter out
imbalances because, you know, if you
just have it set at, you know, any
number one, you know, any low number
that's going to show every imbalance
when you see things in the market like
the stacked imbalance, you know that
you're going to be looking for support,
you want to have genuine, legitimate,
solid buying, right? because an
imbalance is going to be a support or
resistance level over the next few bars.
So, you want to have decent volume being
traded to be support or resistance, you
know, like like in this case, you got a
stacked imbalance here. And you see how
the market is still trading above it for
quite some time. Now, if I used smaller
numbers, you know, if I used um
whatever um you know, 10 or one or five,
you know, I'd get more imbalances. you
know, I'd have a stacked imbalance. Uh,
well, not here, but um, I'm sure I could
find an example
if you give me time.
You know, I'd have stacked imbalance,
stacked buying imbalance right here. One
against 24, two against 23, 6 against
40, which normally I would like off of a
low, but it's not going to hold. Why?
Because this volume is is quite thin,
even though these are technically
imbalances.
So hopefully by now you should
understand you know the importance of
that and and how to use it. I said you
know 50 is my general number that I use
on pretty much all markets. Now there
are some charts that I use smaller
numbers you know or if you want you
could use larger numbers. There was a
time where I was trading a grain
contract and I had it set at 250 because
you know I wanted only major imbalances.
Okay. And again, you know, there's times
where some markets I use I have charts
for imbalances of over 10 to one. Okay,
so again, you know, it depends on your
trading style. You know, some people
love imbalances, some people not, you
know, not really sold on it. Again, it
depends on you. I think imbalances are
very important and a major part of order
flow. So, you know, hopefully this
should answer your questions about
imbalance and and that setting, you
know, why you should use certain
numbers. And thanks for watching this
video. Um, to learn more about my
orderflows chart, visit my website,
orderflows.com.
And thanks and subscribe to my YouTube
channel. When I get new videos, uh,
you'll be alerted to them. Bye-bye.